Alright Andy, what do you want to build,
or what kind of report do you want to make?
>> I really like those little needle sort of, you know, the one that
actually shows up in your car dashboard and says like, oh you spent this
much. And if it's green you're really happy, but that would have to do
with, you know, have you made as much money as you were hoping for?
>> So, I think you're talking about an odometer in your car.
>> Yes.
>> And then what you're talking about in Salesforce would be a gauge chart.
>> Okay, let's make a gauge chart with a needle.
>> Yeah.
So, in order to do that for total revenue on the entire festival,
we need to go down to the attendee and create a formula field first
on how much each attendee spent. Because we know how many tickets we have,
or how many tickets they purchased, and we know how much a ticket costs.
>> Remember they also have different ticket prices, so like the
V.I.P. ticket will be like a $100 and general admission $50.
>> Exactly. And so that's probably why a
formula field would make the most sense in order
to store that data around that conditional use case.
>> Okay, so add a formula on attendees
to figure how much money each one's spending?
>> Yeah, let's start off that.